Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，比如咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的意式浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I met her in the Osteria Bavaria. She was very romantic. The Osteria was a small inn. It's still there and it hasn't changed much. Small tables. There was a wooden partition and behind it a table to seat eight. An adjutant would phone the owner to warn that Hitler might be coming and to have the table clear. There was also a courtyard with one table under a pergola and this was Hitler's favourite seat when the weather was not cold.
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我在巴伐利亚小酒馆（Osteria Bavaria）遇见了她。她非常浪漫。那家小酒馆是一家小旅店。它至今还在那里，也没什么变化。小桌子。那里有一个木隔断，后面有一张能坐八个人的桌子。副官会打电话给老板，提醒希特勒可能要来，让他们把桌子腾出来。还有一个庭院，凉棚下有一张桌子，天气不冷的时候，这是希特勒最喜欢坐的地方。
Unity was quite often there. I was invited only every second or third time. Like me, Mitford would be invited by the adjutant Schaub. She was highly in love with Hitler. We could see it easily. Her face brightened up, her eyes gleaming, staring at Hitler. Hero worship. Absolutely phenomenal. And possibly Hitler liked to be admired by a young woman. She was quite attractive. Even if nothing happened, he was excited by the possibility of a love affair with her. Towards an attractive woman, he behaved as a 17-year-old would. So that was international man of mystery and all-round villain, Rudolf Hess, talking about unity in Mitford. And Tom, we ended last time with the British fascist movement, I think it's fair to say, in the doldrums. World War II had broken out. A lot of the leading fascists, but not all of the aristocrats, but a lot of the other leading
尤妮蒂经常在那里。我每两三次才会被邀请一次。像我一样，米特福德也是由副官绍布邀请的。她深深地爱着希特勒。我们一眼就能看出来。她面容焕发，双眼闪烁，凝视着希特勒。那是对英雄的崇拜。绝对令人惊叹。希特勒可能也喜欢被一位年轻女性仰慕。她很有魅力。即使什么都没发生，他也会因为可能与她发生恋情而感到兴奋。面对有魅力的女性，他的表现就像个 17 岁的少年。以上就是那位国际神秘人物、全能恶棍鲁道夫·赫斯谈论尤妮蒂·米特福德的内容。汤姆，我们上次结束时，英国法西斯运动可以说正处于低谷。第二次世界大战已经爆发。许多法西斯头目，虽然不是所有的贵族，但许多其他主要的
fascists, including Sir Oswald Mosley, have been put into prison. But we're now going to backtrack a little bit because you're very keen to tell the story of the person you regard as Britain's most notorious Nazi. And I say Nazi, not British fascist, because this is somebody, as we've just heard in that sort of barbara cartland-esque prose yes you know she's not at cable street she's not going to grimy meetings and of the sort of scunthorpe branch of the buf she is actually there in germany with the fuhrer and that's unity mitford it is i mean she is probably i mean not probably she is the, I mean, not probably, she is the British person who has the most access to Hitler. I mean, possibly of any foreigner. She has meetings with Hitler over 140 times. And I would go further
法西斯分子，包括奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利爵士，都已被关进监狱。但我们现在要稍微回溯一下，因为你非常热衷于讲述你认为英国最臭名昭著的纳粹分子的故事。我说的是纳粹，而不是英国法西斯分子，因为正如我们刚才在那种芭芭拉·卡特兰式的散文中听到的那样，她不在缆车街，她不去参加英国法西斯联盟（BUF）斯肯索普分部那种肮脏的会议，她实际上是和元首在一起，那就是尤妮蒂·米特福德。我是说，她可能，不，不是可能，她就是与希特勒接触最多的英国人。我是说，可能是所有外国人中接触最多的。她与希特勒会面超过 140 次。而且我还要进一步说
and say that although obviously Oswald Mosley and indeed Unity Mitford's sister Diana, who marries Oswald Mosley, are more significant figures within the history of British fascism. I would say that Unity Mitford is probably the best known British fascist among the general public, simply because there is such a fascination, enduring fascination with the Mitford sisters. And so I think that it's worth having an episode on her, partly because of the inherent fascination of the story. I mean, she is an intriguing figure, but also because I think the fact that a self-avowed Nazi can be integrated into a crucial part of the heritage industry is really, really interesting. So the first biography that was written of Unity Mitford, one of the six famous Mitford sisters, was by a man called David Price-Jones in in 1977 and he subtitled
虽然奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，以及尤妮蒂·米特福德的姐姐戴安娜（她嫁给了奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利），显然是英国法西斯主义史上更重要的人物。但我认为，尤妮蒂·米特福德可能是公众眼中最广为人知的英国法西斯分子，仅仅是因为人们对米特福德姐妹有着持久的迷恋。所以我认为值得为她做一期节目，部分是因为这个故事本身就具有吸引力。她是个人物，但我认为一个自称纳粹的人能被整合进遗产产业的关键部分，这真的非常非常有趣。所以，关于尤妮蒂·米特福德（六位著名的米特福德姐妹之一）的第一本传记是由大卫·普莱斯-琼斯在 1977 年撰写的，他给这本书起的副标题是
it the frivolity of evil which is a play on the banality of evil it's a i think a brilliant title yeah and i think that there is a sense perhaps in which part of the appeal of fascism and by extension nazism in 1930s britain there is an element of that the frivolity of it do you think among the upper classes uh i well i think we talked in the last three episodes about the paranoia among much of the upper classes. So there are definitely people like the, I don't know, in the 1920s, the Duke of Northumberland, very rich, very entitled people who feel genuinely,
“邪恶的轻浮”，这是对“平庸的邪恶”的一种戏仿，我认为这是一个绝妙的标题。是的，我认为在某种程度上，20 世纪 30 年代的英国，法西斯主义（进而延伸到纳粹主义）之所以有吸引力，其中确实包含了一种轻浮的成分。你认为在上层阶级中是这样吗？嗯，我想我们在过去三期节目中谈到了上层阶级中普遍存在的偏执。所以肯定有像——我不知道，20 世纪 20 年代的诺森伯兰公爵那样的人，非常有钱，非常有特权，他们感到真诚的、
almost hysterically afraid of Bolshevism and of sellout by the mainstream political parties and so on. But in the case of the Mitfords, I agree with you. There's a slight sense of incredibly sinister sort of role playing that has got out of control. Yeah. But I think the fascinating thing you said about the heritage industry. So I live, as lots of listeners will know, in North Oxfordshire, very close to the Mitford family estate.
近乎歇斯底里的恐惧，害怕布尔什维克主义，害怕被主流政党出卖等等。但在米特福德一家的案例中，我同意你的看法。有一种失控的、极其阴险的角色扮演感。是的。但我认为你提到的关于遗产产业的事情非常迷人。正如许多听众所知，我住在牛津郡北部，离米特福德家族的庄园非常近。
And there are walking tours. There are Mitford walking tours. I know people. I mean, I know people, Tom, otherwise sane, well-adjusted people who are obsessed with the Mitfords, who love the Mitford sisters, who like going to the graveyard
那里有徒步旅行。有米特福德徒步旅行。我认识一些人，汤姆，平时理智、正常的人，他们对米特福德一家着迷，他们喜欢米特福德姐妹，喜欢去墓地
and seeing the Mitford's graves, who have lots of books on the Mitfords. Now, for a lot of our overseas listeners, this will all be babble. They won't know who the Mitfords are. So perhaps you should explain just who this extraordinary family are and why they have this hold over the british imagination okay so the mitfords are a very ancient family they had lands in england even
看米特福德一家的坟墓，他们有很多关于米特福德一家的书。现在，对于我们许多海外听众来说，这可能都是胡言乱语。他们不知道米特福德一家是谁。所以也许你应该解释一下这个非凡的家庭到底是谁，以及为什么他们对英国人的想象力有如此大的掌控力。好的，米特福德家族是一个非常古老的家族，他们在英格兰甚至
before the norman conquest given to them by edward the confessor up in northumberland very near my scottish estate as it happens on the banks of tweets but there's a kind of junior family from hampshire and these are the ones that end up with lands in the Cotswolds. And the thing about the Mitfords is there are aspects of their heritage that seem to precondition them for a particular interest in Nazism. So I'll go through Unity Mitford's grandparents. So her grandfather on her father's side, so that's the Mitford side. He was a very distinguished diplomat, served in Japan and all over the world, incredible linguist. And he became a very good friend of Richard Wagner.
在诺曼征服之前就拥有土地，是忏悔者爱德华赐予他们的，位于诺森伯兰郡，碰巧离我的苏格兰庄园很近，就在特威德河畔。但有一个来自汉普郡的旁系家族，他们最终在科茨沃尔德拥有了土地。关于米特福德一家，他们的遗产中有些方面似乎预设了他们对纳粹主义的特殊兴趣。所以我来梳理一下尤妮蒂·米特福德的祖父母。她父亲那边的祖父，也就是米特福德这一边。他是一位非常杰出的外交官，曾在日本和世界各地任职，是一位了不起的语言学家。他成了理查德·瓦格纳的好朋友。
He went to Bayreuth. He saw all the Wagnerian operas, including Die Walküre. So all these operas that Hitler was obsessed with. Absolutely. So Hitler will come to know this and they tell the story of statuesque goddesses, blonde hair, who gallop around on horses, picking up the fallen dead and taking them to Valhalla. While he's at Bayreuth, he meets Houston Stuart Chamberlain, Dominic, who we've had calls to mention in this series and indeed in the episode that we did on the rise of the Nazis. So he is British, but he becomes actually in 1916. So during the First World War, he becomes a naturalized German subject and he is vehemently anti-Semitic and the Mitford sisters grandfather translates
他去了拜罗伊特。他观看了所有的瓦格纳歌剧，包括《女武神》。所以希特勒痴迷的所有这些歌剧。绝对是。所以希特勒会知道这一点，他们讲述了那些雕像般的女神的故事，金色的头发，骑着马四处奔跑，捡起阵亡的士兵并将他们带到瓦尔哈拉。当他在拜罗伊特时，他遇到了休斯顿·斯图尔特·张伯伦，多米尼克，我们在本系列节目中提到过他，实际上在我们制作的关于纳粹崛起的剧集中也提到过。所以他是英国人，但实际上在 1916 年，也就是第一次世界大战期间，他成为了入籍的德国公民，他极其反犹，而米特福德姐妹的祖父翻译了
his book, the foundations of the 19th century into English. So he'd written it in German. So, you know, there's a bit of history there. Her paternal grandmother was the sister of clementine churchill's mother so the woman who clementine who marries winston churchill yeah so so that's an additional part of the mix and the mitford sisters in fact often go to chartwell to see cousin winston and churchill wasn't particularly interested in most of the Mitford sisters, although he admired Diana, who was by some way the most beautiful. And Randolph, his son, has a massive, massive crush on Diana, as pretty much everyone in London society does. So their grandfather on their mother's side, he was also an absolutely massive anti-Semite. He goes on a journey through the Holy Land, goes to Jerusalem, and he says of the Jews, if they have been expelled from jerusalem they are the rulers of london paris and berlin and his daughter so
他的书《十九世纪的基础》并将其译成英文。所以他是用德语写的。所以，你知道，那里有一段历史。她的祖母是克莱门汀·丘吉尔母亲的姐妹，也就是嫁给温斯顿·丘吉尔的那个克莱门汀。是的，所以这是组合中的额外部分。事实上，米特福德姐妹经常去查特韦尔看望温斯顿表亲，而丘吉尔对大多数米特福德姐妹并不特别感兴趣，尽管他很欣赏戴安娜，她算是最漂亮的一个。而他的儿子伦道夫对戴安娜有非常非常强烈的迷恋，就像伦敦社交界的几乎每个人一样。所以她们母亲那边的祖父，他也是一个绝对狂热的反犹分子。他去圣地旅行，去了耶路撒冷，他谈到犹太人时说，如果他们被逐出耶路撒冷，他们就是伦敦、巴黎和柏林的统治者。而他的女儿，也就是
that the mother of the mitfords sydney seems to have inherited this instinctive anti-semitism although she was a great admirer of the mosaic dietary laws because she firmly believed that jews never got cancer and attributed this to their not eating pork or shellfish. So she... That's a very unusual medical opinion, isn't it? Yes. Yes. So their father, David, who in Nancy Mitford's pursuit of love is Uncle Matthew, you know, hates foreigners, damn foreigners, all that kind of thing.
米特福德姐妹的母亲悉尼，似乎继承了这种本能的反犹主义，尽管她非常推崇摩西饮食法，因为她坚信犹太人从不得癌症，并将此归因于他们不吃猪肉或贝类。所以她……那是一个非常不寻常的医学观点，不是吗？是的。是的。所以她们的父亲大卫，在南希·米特福德的《追求爱》中是马修叔叔，你知道，讨厌外国人，该死的外国人，诸如此类。
So he becomes lord reedsdale when his his brother dies in the in the first world war so he's the younger son but inherits the title because his brother dies he is a spectacularly hopeless investor so every investment he makes goes wrong and at one point he um decides to go gold prospecting in canada so he buys a gold mine at a place called Swastika. You couldn't make that up, could you? It'd be on parody. He goes out there with Sydney, his wife,
所以当他的哥哥在第一次世界大战中去世后，他成为了里兹代尔勋爵，所以他是次子，但因为哥哥去世而继承了爵位。他是一个极其无可救药的投资者，所以他做的每一项投资都出了问题。有一次，他决定去加拿大淘金，所以他在一个叫“万字”（Swastika）的地方买了一个金矿。你编都编不出这种事，对吧？这简直是讽刺。他和他的妻子悉尼去了那里，
and there Sydney conceives their fourth daughter and fifth child, who, when she is born, is given the name not just of Unity, but of Valkyrie. So after Di Valkyrie. Yeah. On the recommendation of her paternal grandfather. So she is unity Valkyrie Mitford. And so all of this is giving her a certain pedigree, a certain heritage. So she is one of seven children. So the oldest is Nancy in 1903, Pamela in 1907, Pamela is the boring one. Tom, 1909, he's the male one. Diana in 1910,
在那里，悉尼怀上了她们的第四个女儿和第五个孩子，当她出生时，被取名为尤妮蒂（Unity），而且还加上了瓦尔基里（Valkyrie）。所以是“女武神”。是的。是在她祖父的建议下取的。所以她是尤妮蒂·瓦尔基里·米特福德。所以这一切都给了她某种血统，某种遗产。所以她是七个孩子之一。最年长的是 1903 年出生的南希，1907 年出生的帕梅拉，帕梅拉是那个无聊的。1909 年出生的汤姆，他是唯一的男性。1910 年出生的戴安娜，
she's the beautiful one. And then there is a gap of four years. And so Unity is born in 1914 during the first world war, which makes the fact that she's given this name of Valkyrie all the more extraordinary. And then you have Jessica who comes to be known as Deca and then Deborah, who comes to be known as Debo. So it's an amazing accumulation of children. And all of them will have astonishing careers, which is why they are objects of such popular fascination. But I think for our purposes, by miles, the most interesting one is Unity, because she goes even further than Diana.
她是那个漂亮的。然后中间有四年的间隔。所以尤妮蒂出生于 1914 年，也就是第一次世界大战期间，这使得她被取名为“瓦尔基里”这一事实更加非同寻常。然后是杰西卡，后来被称为德卡（Deca），还有黛博拉，后来被称为德博（Debo）。所以这是一个惊人的孩子数量。他们每个人后来都有了令人震惊的职业生涯，这就是为什么他们成为大众迷恋的对象。但我认为，就我们的目的而言，最有趣的人绝对是尤妮蒂，因为她比戴安娜走得更远。
Even further than Diana, who's actually married the leader of the British Union of Fascists. And in fact, because Unity, Jessica and Deborah are born, you know, several years after Diana, they are kind of grouped together as the young girls. And so they all slightly live in Diana's shadow. Diana is incredibly beautiful, incredibly glamorous. And so Unity, I think in particular, feels that she has to show off if she is going to make a mark. And so that's what she does. And her character is enhanced by the fact that compared to the other girls, she is very big bone. She's very galumphing. Statuesque, you might want to say. And she has these kind of incredibly large, baleful eyes. And she developed the technique of sitting at table slowly shoveling mashed potato
甚至比嫁给了英国法西斯联盟领袖的戴安娜走得更远。事实上，因为尤妮蒂、杰西卡和黛博拉出生在戴安娜之后几年，她们被归为“小女孩”一类。所以她们都有点生活在戴安娜的阴影下。戴安娜非常漂亮，非常有魅力。所以尤妮蒂，我认为特别是她，觉得如果她想出人头地，就必须炫耀自己。所以她就是这么做的。她的性格因一个事实而增强，那就是与其他女孩相比，她骨架很大。她非常笨拙。或者说雕像般。她有一双非常大、阴郁的眼睛。她养成了一种习惯，坐在桌边慢慢地把土豆泥
into her mouth gazing at her father and her father would become more and more furious by this and he'd bellow at her stop staring at me and she would continue to stare at him then he would absolutely explode and she would slide under the table and stay there and refuse to come out and she obviously took a pleasure in rousing her father to a condition of absolute fury. And I think there's a sense in which of all the girls, she is perhaps the most difficult to handle. So the Reesdales, like a lot of aristocratic families at this time, did not approve of sending their daughters to school. They saw that as vulgar. Nancy Mitford said of her father that he thought one got thick calves from playing hockey. He didn't want that at all.
塞进嘴里，盯着她的父亲，她的父亲会因此变得越来越愤怒，他会对着她咆哮：“别盯着我！”而她会继续盯着他，然后他会彻底爆发，她就会滑到桌子底下，待在那里拒绝出来。她显然从激怒父亲到绝对愤怒的状态中获得了乐趣。我认为在某种程度上，在所有女孩中，她也许是最难对付的。所以里兹代尔一家，像当时许多贵族家庭一样，不赞成送女儿去学校。他们认为那很庸俗。南希·米特福德曾说她父亲认为打曲棍球会让小腿变粗。他一点也不想要那样。
Yeah. But they find unity so stressful to have around that they do actually send her to school. And on both occasions, she ends up being expelled. And the final time she's 17, Lord Reesdale himself goes to the school to try and persuade the headmistress to take her back. And the headmistress refuses. Right. Meanwhile, as unity is kind of going to school being expelled
是的。但他们觉得尤妮蒂在身边太让人心烦了，所以他们确实把她送去了学校。但两次她最终都被开除了。最后一次她 17 岁时，里兹代尔勋爵亲自去学校试图说服女校长让她回去。但女校长拒绝了。好吧。与此同时，当尤妮蒂在学校被开除时，
coming out of school wondering what to do diana is out there she is a society beauty she's a bright young thing um she's married brian guinness who's fabulously rich evelyn war is dedicating bodies to her and for unity you can see that this makes her even more glamorous than she'd been uh when they were children and she kind of like a moth drawn to a a flame she immediately starts hanging out with diana yeah and thinking you know this is the person who i want to impress so 1932 she comes out which doesn't mean that she doesn't have the connotation that it has today. It means that she joins this kind of circle of gals who are upper class, who are being presented at the court, who are circulating around various dances and parties and so on with the aim of meeting a handsome young man. But Unity, she cuts a tremendous dash.
离开学校后不知道该做什么，戴安娜已经在外面了，她是社交界的宠儿，她是那个时代的“明亮年轻人”……她嫁给了极其富有的布莱恩·吉尼斯，伊夫林·沃把《尸体》献给了她，对于尤妮蒂来说，你可以看出这让她比她们小时候看起来更有魅力，她就像一只飞蛾扑向火焰，她立刻开始和戴安娜混在一起。是的，心想，你知道，这就是我想打动的人。所以 1932 年她初入社交界，这并不意味着它没有今天那样的内涵。这意味着她加入了这个上层阶级女孩的圈子，她们在宫廷中被引荐，在各种舞会和派对中穿梭，目的是结识英俊的年轻人。但尤妮蒂，她非常引人注目。
So the Daily Express in the summer of 1932 uh comments on her that she was the prettiest girl right because it's a bit like red carpets today people are interested in debutantes devs as they're called yes um but unity is i think an intimidating figure to men she's she's very as i said statuesque. She has a fondness for stunts. She has a rat, Ratchela, which she keeps in her handbag. And at dances, she will take it out and stroke it. That's very Ron Weasley behavior, Tom, for our Harry Potter listeners. She also has a snake called Enid.
所以《每日快报》在 1932 年夏天评论说她是当时最漂亮的女孩，因为这有点像今天的红地毯，人们对初入社交界的女孩（debutantes，简称 devs）很感兴趣。是的，嗯，但我认为尤妮蒂对男人来说是一个令人生畏的人物，她非常，正如我所说，雕像般。她喜欢特技。她有一只老鼠，叫拉切拉（Ratchela），她把它放在手提包里。在舞会上，她会把它拿出来抚摸。汤姆，这对我们的哈利·波特听众来说是非常罗恩·韦斯莱的行为。她还有一条叫伊妮德（Enid）的蛇。
And the story goes is that she kind of will on occasion wear it instead of a necklace. Now, I'm not entirely convinced whether that's true. These stories seem to come from her younger sister, Jessica, who is prone to exaggeration. And the simple reason I'm hesitant about that, applying all my historical acumen, is that I think rats and snakes don't necessarily get on well. Well, Theo, our producer says this is all very Nazi behavior. I mean, this is very kind of Nazis in an Indiana Jones film. Except that at this point, Unity still has absolutely no interest in politics, let alone in fascism. Right. But 1932 is the year in which Diana Guinness, as she is by this point, starts her affair with Oswald Mosley.
故事是说她有时会把它当作项链戴在身上。现在，我不太确定这是不是真的。这些故事似乎来自她的小妹妹杰西卡，她倾向于夸大其词。我对此犹豫不决的简单原因是，运用我所有的历史敏锐度，我认为老鼠和蛇不一定能相处得很好。好吧，我们的制片人西奥说这都是非常纳粹的行为。我是说，这非常像《夺宝奇兵》电影里的纳粹。除了在这一点上，尤妮蒂对政治仍然毫无兴趣，更不用说法西斯主义了。好吧。但 1932 年是戴安娜·吉尼斯（她当时的名字）开始与奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利发生婚外情的一年。
And Unity is kind of coming along in the train. So that actually, you know, they all go to a ball hosted by Lady Rothschild, who is obviously a very significant Jewish society figure. Neither Diana nor Unity have any problem with this at all. But by October 32, Mosley is starting to go full fascist. So he's putting on the black shirts, he's holding his rallies. You know, we talked about this in the previous episode. Exactly. Yes. Meanwhile, Unity is, she's still oblivious to this she's become an art student she actually seems to be very good at art and you could imagine her becoming a kind of bohemian figure a posh bohemian figure yeah i love posh bohemian figures as you know tom
而尤妮蒂有点跟在后面。所以实际上，你知道，她们都去参加了罗斯柴尔德夫人举办的舞会，她显然是一位非常重要的犹太社交名流。戴安娜和尤妮蒂对此都没有任何问题。但到了 32 年 10 月，莫斯利开始全面转向法西斯主义。所以他穿上了黑衫，举行集会。你知道，我们在上一集谈过这个。没错。是的。与此同时，尤妮蒂仍然对此一无所知，她成了一名艺术系学生，她似乎在艺术方面非常有天赋，你可以想象她成为一种波西米亚式的人物，一个时髦的波西米亚人物。是的，我知道你喜欢时髦的波西米亚人物，汤姆。
i know you do dominic i know you do but we talked in the previous episode how Moseley's wife, Simi, who is the daughter of Lord Curzon, even as Oswald Moseley is having his affair with Diana, she falls very dangerously ill. So she has a burst appendix. Moseley goes to hospital with her, spends the morning with her, then goes out and has lunch with Diana. And Unity is with Diana. And she is immediately besotted with him idolizes him calls him the leader joins the fascists and becomes actually you know you were saying that she's not out there walking the streets actually she does start walking the streets she starts selling the black shirt on the streets of oxford she takes it quite seriously yeah although seriousness with
我知道你喜欢，多米尼克，我知道你喜欢。但我们在上一集谈到莫斯利的妻子西米（寇松勋爵的女儿），即使奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利与戴安娜有染，她也病得非常严重。所以她阑尾穿孔了。莫斯利陪她去医院，上午陪她，然后出去和戴安娜吃午饭。而尤妮蒂和戴安娜在一起。她立刻被他迷住了，崇拜他，称他为“领袖”，加入了法西斯组织，实际上，你知道，你说她没有走上街头，但她确实开始走上街头了，她开始在牛津街头兜售《黑衫报》，她相当认真地对待这件事。是的，尽管米特福德一家的认真总是相对的。所以安东尼·伦博德有一段精彩的描述，他是霍勒斯·伦博德的儿子，霍勒斯在纳粹掌权前夕是驻德国大使。他去了斯温布鲁克，米特福德家族的庄园。顺便说一句，那里很可爱。斯温布鲁克是一个美丽的村庄。大卫·卡梅伦曾和弗朗索瓦·奥朗德去那里喝过一杯。所以如果你去那家酒吧，墙上有卡梅伦和奥朗德的照片。是的，我敢打赌他去了。总之，尤妮蒂和共产主义者杰西卡在那里，两个女孩围住这个可怜的家伙安东尼·伦博德，问：“你是法西斯还是共产主义者？”
the mitfords is always relative so there's a brilliant account by Anthony Rumbold, who's the son of Horace Rumbold, who was ambassador to Germany in the buildup to the Nazis taking power. And he goes down to Swinbrook, the Mitford estate. Which is lovely, by the way. Swinbrook is a beautiful village. David Cameron went there with François Hollande for a pint. So if you go to the pub, there's pictures in the wall of Cameron Hollande. Yeah, I bet he did. Anyway, so Unity is there with Jessica, the communist, and the two girls set on this poor chap, Anthony Rumbold, and say, are you a fascist or a communist?
他说：“嗯，我两者都不是。我相信民主。”她们回答：“真软弱。”哦，天哪。这非常、非常米特福德。所以实际上尤妮蒂似乎，你知道，她全心全意地投入了法西斯主义，就像她的小妹妹杰西卡成为了一名绝对坚定的斯大林主义者一样。她们都非常沉迷于各自的独裁人物。但我认为在某种程度上，对于尤妮蒂来说，在街上兜售
And he says, well, I'm neither. I believe in democracy. And they answer, how wet? Oh, God. Which is very, very Mitford. So actually Unity seems to, you know, she's thrown herself wholeheartedly into fascism in exactly the way that her younger sister, Jessica has become an absolutely committed Stalinist. They're both very into their respective dictatorial figures. But I think there is a sense in which for unity that the trudging around streets selling
法西斯杂志已经变得无聊了，她已经在想：我想超越……你知道，戴安娜此时已经拿下了奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，她们还没结婚，但她们显然在一起了。她在想：我怎样才能比戴安娜做得更好？当然，你知道，戴安娜有她的法西斯领袖，但还有一个更重要的法西斯领袖，尤妮蒂决定去追求。所以在我们进入那个话题之前，我能问一个稍微严肃点的问题吗？我是说，这些人太不严肃了，我觉得问一个严肃的问题似乎很奇怪，但我还是会问。所以我们在节目早期谈到了一些被法西斯主义吸引的贵族，因为恐惧，因为他们的偏执等等。
fascist magazines is already becoming boring and she is already thinking i want to go beyond what you know diana has by this point has bagged oswald mosley they haven't got married but they're clearly together she's thinking how can i go one better than diana and of course you know diana has her fascist leader but there's an even more significant fascist leader who unity decides to go after so just before we get onto that can i just ask a sort of slightly serious question i mean this is such a these are such unserious people i think that it seems weird to ask a serious question but i'll do it anyway so we talked a little bit early in the episode about other aristocrats who are drawn to fascism because of fear, because of their kind of paranoia and whatnot.
对于尤妮蒂·米特福德，你从来没有提到过她读书，例如。她是那种……这是完全失控的轻浮，邪恶的轻浮，还是有任何严肃和真正的意识形态承诺？我认为在这个阶段，这绝对是轻浮，一种想要震惊他人的欲望。我认为对于戴安娜，她非常聪明，博学，非常、非常聪明，我认为这是经过深思熟虑的。我认为她致力于奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，不仅因为他非常英俊和有魅力，还因为她完全开始相信他所说的话。所以她是一个思考者。尤妮蒂不是一个思考者。
With Unity Mitford, you haven't mentioned her at any point reading a book, for example. Is she somebody who is, this is frivolity that has got completely out of hand, the frivolity of evil, or is there any seriousness and genuine ideological commitment to this at all? I think at this stage, it's absolutely frivolity, a desire to shock. I think with Diana, who's very bright, very well-read, very, very smart, I think it is thought through. I think that she commits herself to Oswald Mosley, not just because he's incredibly good looking and charismatic, but also because she completely comes to believe in what he's saying. So she is a thinker. Unity is not a thinker.
这似乎更多是本能的。所以南希·米特福德，米特福德姐妹中最年长、后来成为非常著名的小说家，在她的一部小说中，她描绘了尤妮蒂作为法西斯分子的形象，并将她与妇女参政论者进行了比较，说在更早的时代，她对事业的渴望，那种想要成为比自己更宏大事物一部分的感觉，很可能导致她去争取妇女投票权。是的，我想也许，几十年后，她可能会成为玛丽安·菲斯福尔那样的人，她可能会成为……她离开了米克·贾格尔的时髦群体。是的，没错。所以我认为她在寻找那种有魅力的男人。我认为她在寻找刺激。她想震惊他人。我是说，我认为所有这些元素，你可以在 60 年代人们的行为方式中看到，我认为它在 30 年代就已经存在了，这可能就是为什么人们，你知道，从 60 年代到现在，如此强烈地认同米特福德一家的原因。她们的整个态度中有一种非常 60 年代的特质。
It seems to be much more instinctive. So Nancy Mitford, the eldest of the Mitford girls who will become very famous novelist, one of her novels, she gives a portrait of Unity as a fascist and compares her to the suffragettes, says that in an earlier earlier age her yearning for a cause the sense that she wants to be part of something bigger than herself might well have led her to campaign for votes for women yeah and i think that maybe you know a few decades later she might have become a kind of marianne faithful equivalent she might have become she's gone out of mcjaggott posh groupie yes yeah exactly so i think that she is looking for kind of charismatic men. I think she's looking for excitement. She wants to shock. I mean, I think all these kind of elements that you can see very much in the way that people behave in the 60s, I think it's already there in the 30s, which may well be why people, you know, through the 60s and into the present day identify with the Mitford so strongly. There's something quite 60s about their whole
但显然对于尤妮蒂来说，它朝着一个非常、非常黑暗的方向发展。她得到了见到希特勒的机会，因为在 1933 年 8 月，她作为英国法西斯代表团的一员前往纽伦堡，代表团中实际上包括威廉·乔伊斯，他后来成为了“霍霍勋爵”，我们在之前的剧集中也谈到过。在纽伦堡，尤妮蒂见到了希特勒。她说：“我见到他的第一眼，就知道没有谁比他更值得我遇见了。”没错。一见钟情。可爱的声音。所以她回到了英国。这就是南希嘲弄她的时候，因为她到处对着希特勒发花痴，
attitude. But obviously with unity, it goes in a very, very dark direction. And she gets her opportunity to meet Hitler because in August 1933, she travels to Nuremberg as part of a delegation of British fascists that actually includes William Joyce, who will go on to become Lord Haw Haw again, who we talked about in earlier episodes. And at Nuremberg, Unity sees Hitler. And she says of him, the first moment I saw him, I knew there was no one I would rather meet. Right. Very good. Love at first sight. Lovely voice. So she goes back to England. And this is when Nancy spoofs her because she is going around mooning over Hitler
就像她在 60 年代对着米克·贾格尔那样。所以她对每个人行纳粹礼，你知道，她会去邮局，脚后跟一磕，说“希特勒万岁”，这一切都非常奇怪。对于杰西卡，她那个共产主义者小妹妹，你以为她会强烈反对这一点。在某种程度上她是反对的，但这仍然有点像一场游戏。就像她们选择了各自的竞争对手流行歌星。你知道，尤妮蒂选择了米克·贾格尔。杰西卡选择了保罗·麦卡特尼。
in the way that she might have done in the 60s over Mick Jagger so she is giving the Hitler salute to everyone you know she'll go down to the post office click her heels and say hi Hitler and it's all very odd and for say for Jessica her younger sister who's the communist who you think would be vehemently opposed to this. On one level she is, but it's still a bit of a game. It's like they've kind of chosen their rival pop stars. You know, Unity's chosen Mick Jagger. Jessica's chosen Paul McCartney.
这种痴迷导致她在第二年，也就是 1934 年春天，去了慕尼黑，她知道希特勒的主要基地在那里。她在一所语言学校注册，就在纳粹总部隔壁。戴安娜也加入了她。整个夏天，整个秋天，她都在鲁道夫·赫斯所描述的巴伐利亚小酒馆里消磨时光。她去了纽伦堡集会，你知道，又有点像去格拉斯顿伯里音乐节之类的，被人群的兴奋所感染。她穿着她的黑衫。她成了所有党卫军军官绝对迷恋的对象。你知道，这个非常像女武神的、法西斯的、金发的贵族，穿着她的法西斯制服。
And this obsession leads to her the following year. So in the spring of 1934, going to Munich, where she knows Hitler has his main base. And she enrolls in a language school right next door to the Nazi headquarters. And she is joined by Diana. All that summer, all that autumn, she spends hanging out in the Osteria Bavaria, as described by Rudolf Hess. She goes to the Nuremberg rallies, you know, again, a bit like going to a Glastonbury or something, get caught up in the excitement of the crowd. She's wearing her black shirt. She becomes an object of absolute fascination to all the SS officers. You know, this very Valkyrie-like, fascist, blonde aristocrat in her fascist uniform.
他们建议她：别化太浓的妆。希特勒不喜欢化妆。所以她非常小心地注意这一点。在她开始去巴伐利亚小酒馆 10 个月后，终于有人走过来对她说：“元首想见你。”她走过去和希特勒待在一起，她写信给她父亲，里兹代尔勋爵：“这是我一生中最美妙、最美好的一天。”我是说，当她见到希特勒时，当她和这些人混在一起时，她脑子里到底在想什么？这些人此时此刻，为了避免怀疑，已经沉浸在暴力和流血之中，并且毫不掩饰他们的……我是说，坦率地说，任何读过《我的奋斗》或希特勒 20 年代演讲的人都会知道，我们在“纳粹崛起”系列中讨论过这一点，他们毫不掩饰他们的总体社会野心。所以她到底在想什么？所以她确实有一本希特勒签名的《我的奋斗》，上面还签了第三帝国几乎所有其他名人的名字，就像一本签名册。关于她在想什么的问题，南希·米特福德，她一直对她很忠诚，尽管南希非常倾向于左翼，她后来写道：
She's advised by them, don't wear too much makeup. Hitler doesn't like makeup. So she watches that very carefully. 10 months after she started going to the Osteria, Bavaria, finally someone comes over and says the Fuhrer would like to meet you. She goes over to hang out with Hitler and she writes to her father, to Lord Reesdale, it was the most wonderful and beautiful day of my life. I mean, what on earth is going on in her head when she's meeting Hitler, when she's hanging around with these people who already at this stage, for the avoidance of doubt, who already steeped in violence and in bloodshed and have made no secret of their, I mean, frankly, anyone who's read Mein Kampf or Hitler's speeches in the 1920s will know, and we discussed this on our Rise of the Nazis series, they have made no secret of their general societal ambitions. So what on earth is she thinking? So she does have a copy of Mein Kampf signed by Hitler and also signed by pretty much every other luminary in the Third Reich, like a kind of autograph book. The question of what she's thinking, so Nancy Mitford, who remained devoted to her, even though Nancy was very much on the left, she wrote later about
关于尤妮蒂，整个纳粹的事情似乎只是个玩笑。她很有趣。她过去常常穿着制服，带着枪在欧洲中部开车。尤妮蒂完全不关心政治。没有人比她更不懂政治了。这就是典型的时髦业余爱好者的借口。哦，这很有趣。我们对政治一无所知。所以我认为其中包含了一些成分。我认为其中包含了一些成分。“哦，这真是太搞笑了。”如果，你知道，如果人们感到震惊，那就更好了。我认为毫无疑问也有一种色情迷恋的感觉，特别是对党卫军。家庭保姆，她以“布鲁尔”这个辉煌的名字为荣，她说：“亲爱的，我真希望你别再去德国了。那些男人。”所以她确实发现了正在发生的事情。或者这只是一个巨大的笑话，或者她这样做是为了震惊他人，这并不能原谅她。因为她完全陷入了纳粹主义最黑暗的方面。她知道如果她想保持
unity that with her, the whole Nazi thing seemed to be a joke. She was great fun. She used to drive around Central Europe in a uniform with a gun. Unity was absolutely unpolitical. No one knew less about politics than she did. That is the classic posh dilettante's get out. Oh, it's great fun. We knew nothing about politics. So I think there is an element of that. I think there is an element. Oh, it's all tremendous laugh. And if, you know, and if people are shocked, then so much the better. I think there is also undoubtedly a sense of kind of erotic fascination, particularly with the SS and the family nanny, who rejoices in the splendid name of Bloor, she says, I do wish you wouldn't keep going to Germany, darling. All those men. So she certainly identified something that's going on. or it's all just a tremendous laugh, or she's doing it to shock, does not excuse her. Because she goes full in on the darkest aspects of Nazism. She knows that if she's going to keep
希特勒的注意力，她必须让自己完全处于他的注视之下。她必须把自己的立场钉在纳粹的桅杆上。所以她通过与一个男人交往来做到这一点，即使以纳粹的标准来看，他也是一个怪物，朱利叶斯·施特莱彻，他编辑《冲锋报》。一个，你知道，光头，留着胡子，看起来像个暴徒的男人。而且，你知道，放在背景中来看，在纽伦堡审判中，其他纳粹分子有点避开施特莱彻，因为他们认为他不仅庸俗，而且认为他是一个怪物。我是说，这就是我们所说的那种人。是的。而且她在英国的贵族圈子里也有很多人说：“但他太粗俗了。”但我认为米特福德一家太时髦了，以至于这并不困扰她们。你可以想象乔治·奥威尔，例如，为此感到纠结，为米特福德一家感到极其尴尬。有一种感觉，即这么多纳粹分子非常“非 U”（Non-U）——用南希·米特福德的术语来说，U 和非 U，U 是 7% 的人口，非 U 是另外 93%——所以尤妮蒂觉得完全没有必要为了她自己的上层阶级习俗或行为而妥协，因为她知道实际上像施特莱彻这样的人会喜欢那样。所以有一种上层阶级和下层阶级之间的共同感，再次，像奥威尔这样的人永远无法接受。他会为此感到太尴尬了。所以尤妮蒂和施特莱彻走得很近，他是，你知道，负责媒体的。所以这是
Hitler's attention, she has to keep herself kind of absolutely within his gaze. She has to nail her colours to the Nazi mast. And so she does this by taking up with a man who, even by the standards of the Nazis, is a monster, Julius Streicher, who edits De Sturmer, the stormtrooper. A man who, you know, shaven head, moustache, looks like a thug. And, you know, to put it into context, at the Nuremberg trials, the other Nazis kind of avoided Streicher because they regarded him not merely as vulgar, but as they regarded him as a monster. I mean, that's the kind of person we're talking about. Yes. And also quite a lot of people in Britain from her aristocratic circle say, but he's so common. But I think there's an element in which the Mitfords are so posh that that doesn't bother them. You can imagine George Orwell, for instance, tying himself up
对莫斯利来说相当重要的人物。所以当莫斯利在莱斯特发表演讲时，施特莱彻给他发了一封电报说：“你知道，祝贺你，我非常赞同你发表的演讲。”莫斯利回电说：“在欧洲成功实现和平与正义之前，必须在所有国家摧毁犹太腐败的力量。”所以他也在反犹主义上投入巨大。而且有趣的是，这显然没有在斯基多夫斯基勋爵的传记中引用。可以在欧洲成功实现和平与正义。所以他也在反犹主义上投入巨大。而且有趣的是，这显然没有在斯基多夫斯基勋爵的传记中引用。它在大卫·普莱斯-琼斯关于尤妮蒂的传记中被引用了，引起了相当大的轰动。
in knots about this, feeling incredibly embarrassed for the for the mitfeds there's a sense in which the fact that so many of the nazis are very non-you yeah to use nancy mitfeds terminology you and non-you you is acceptable seven percent of the population and non-you is the other 93 so unity feels absolutely no requirement to kind of compromise with her own upper class mores or or behavior because she knows that actually people like Stryker will love that. So there's a kind of sense of a commonality between the upper classes and the lower classes that again, someone like Orwell would never be able to buy into. He'd be far too embarrassed about it. So unity goes in big with Stryker who is, you know, in charge of the press. So it's
但我认为莫斯利确实发了。有一种感觉，尤妮蒂正在充当纳粹德国的重要权力玩家和英国法西斯联盟之间的经纪人。有趣的是，这正是莫斯利开始转向的时刻，1934 年左右，1935 年，莫斯利自己也全面转向反犹主义，这是他在 1932 年建立英国法西斯联盟时并没有真正提到的事情。所以我怀疑他的小姨子，大概还有他的妻子，她们都处于这种日益增长的反犹主义氛围中。
quite a significant figure for Moseley. And so when Moseley gives a speech in Leicester, Stryker sends him a telegram saying, you know, congratulations, I very much approve of the speech you gave. And Moseley sends him a telegram back saying the power of Jewish corruption must be destroyed in all countries before peace and justice can be successfully achieved in Europe. So he's going in big on the antisemitism as well. And actually intriguingly, that apparently was not quoted in the Lord Skidowski biography. can be successfully achieved in Europe. So he's going in big on the anti-Semitism as well. And actually, intriguingly, that apparently was not quoted in the Lord Skidowski biography. It was quoted in the David Price Jones biography of unity, caused quite a stir.
我认为戴安娜和莫斯利肯定没那么严重。你可以看出来，因为你只需要看看尤妮蒂在做什么，她可是全力以赴。所以她给《冲锋报》写了一封信，信中说：“我们迫切需要像《冲锋报》这样的出版物来告诉人们真相。人们很快就会看到，希望在英国，尽管有敌人的狡猾，我们也能战胜世界公敌。”所以她是在谈论犹太人。我们期待着那一天，我们将以全部的力量和威力宣布：英国属于英国人，犹太人滚出去。德国式问候，希特勒万岁，尤妮蒂·米特福德。附言：如果你的报纸恰好有空间刊登这封信，请打印我的全名。我不希望我的信只用 UM 缩写，因为每个人都应该知道我是一个犹太仇恨者。所以她绝对把自己的立场钉在了桅杆上。而施特莱彻，当他刊登这封信时（他确实刊登了），他把它印在了报纸的显眼位置。他还确保告诉他的读者，尤妮蒂是
But I mean, Mosley definitely sent it. And there's a sense in which unity is acting as a broker between the significant power players in Nazi Germany and the British Union of Fascists. And it's interesting that this is the exact point when Mosley is beginning, 1934 or so, 1935, Mosley is going all in on the antisemitism himself, something that he hadn't really mentioned in 1932 when he set up the British Union of Fascists. So I wonder whether his sister-in-law, presumably his wife, they're all in this atmosphere of increasing anti-Semitism.
温斯顿·丘吉尔的亲戚。这使她在英国和德国都极具新闻价值，当然，它完全实现了尤妮蒂想要实现的目标，即它给了她在希特勒面前的信誉。好吧，汤姆，在我们开始之前，我向你明确表示，我非常强烈地反对米特福德一家，我不得不说，你在过去半小时里所说的一切都没有改变我的立场哪怕一点点。事实上，我比我们开始之前更讨厌她们了。所以带着这个重磅炸弹，我想我们应该休息一下，休息后我们将回来了解尤妮蒂·米特福德的遭遇，她与希特勒的关系。而且汤姆，我希望你能解开历史上最迷人的谜团之一。我们喜欢《历史余温》中的谜团，不是吗？尤妮蒂·米特福德有希特勒的孩子吗？等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的意式浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 意式浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告
I think Diana and mostly definitely less so. And you can tell that because you just have to look at what Unity is doing, who is going full in. So she writes a letter to Der Sturmer in which she says, we urgently need a publication like Sturmer to tell the people the truth. They will soon see it is to be hoped that in England too, we shall be victorious over the world enemy in spite of his cunning. So she's talking about the Jews there. We look forward to the day on which we shall declare with full power and might, England for the English, Jews out, with German greetings, Heil Hitler, unity Mitford. P.S. If you should happen to find room in your paper for this letter, please print my name in full. I do not want my letter initialed UM, for everyone should know that I am a Jew-hater. So she is absolutely pinning her colors to the mast. And Stryker, when he prints this letter, which he does, he blazes it over his newspaper. He also makes sure to tell his readers that unity is related
收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。人们有一种感觉，尤妮蒂处于比情妇更有利的地位，更受保护，因为不依赖于那种易变的身体纽带。她可以坐着喋喋不休，这是情妇永远不敢做的。她与希特勒的亲密关系比那更奇怪。她是轻松的调剂，是妹妹、宫廷小丑和护身符的结合体。他也可能喜欢这样一个事实：他的心腹并不真的想让她在那里，但又不能说出来。他对英国印象深刻，对它指挥帝国的能力着迷，
to Winston Churchill. and this makes her incredibly newsworthy in britain in germany and of course it achieves exactly what unity wants it to achieve namely it gives her credibility with hitler well tom before we started i said i made it very clear to you that i disapproved very strongly of the mitfords and i'm i have to say that nothing you've said in the last half hour has changed that position one iota. In fact, I hate them even more than I did before we started. So on that bombshell, I think we should take a break and we will return after the break to find out what happened to Unity Mitford, her relationship with Hitler. And Tom, you will be able to solve, I hope, one of history's most intriguing mysteries. We love a mystery on The Rest is
温斯顿·丘吉尔。这使她在英国和德国都极具新闻价值，当然，这也完全达到了尤妮蒂想要的效果，即让她在希特勒面前获得了信誉。汤姆，在我们开始之前，我就明确告诉你，我非常不赞同米特福德一家，我不得不说，你在过去半小时里所说的一切，并没有改变我的立场分毫。事实上，我比开始前更讨厌她们了。带着这个重磅炸弹，我想我们应该休息一下，休息过后我们将回来了解尤妮蒂·米特福德的遭遇，以及她与希特勒的关系。汤姆，我希望你能解开历史上最引人入胜的谜团之一。我们热爱《历史余温》中的谜团，
History, don't we? Did Unity Mitford have Hitler's child? Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free
不是吗？尤妮蒂·米特福德生下了希特勒的孩子吗？等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改你的拿铁订单还来得及吗？但如果有一台KitchenAid浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些想法了，因为你本可以在家自己制作浓缩咖啡。立即前往KitchenAid.ca选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告
listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. One has the sense that unity was in a preferable position to a mistress, more protected because not dependent upon that mutable physical tie. She could sit and babble away as a mistress would never have dared. Her intimacy with Hitler was odder than that. She was light relief, a combination of younger sister, court jester, and talisman. He may also have enjoyed the fact that his henchmen did not really want her there, but could not say so. He was impressed by Britain, fascinated by its ability to command an empire,
收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。人们有一种感觉，尤妮蒂处于比情妇更优越的位置，因为她更受保护，不必依赖那种不稳定的肉体关系。她可以坐着喋喋不休，这是情妇绝不敢做的。她与希特勒的亲密关系比那更奇怪。她是轻松的调剂，是小妹妹、宫廷小丑和护身符的结合体。他可能也很享受他的心腹们并不真正希望她在场，却又不敢说出来的事实。他对英国印象深刻，对它统治帝国的能力着迷，
and like so many people, he was compelled by the British aristocracy. In his way, he was probably impressed by unity herself. Quite simply, Hitler felt happier with her around. So that, Tom, is Laura Thompson in Take Six Girls, The Lives of the Mitford Sisters. So this is the real core of the story, isn't it? Unity Mitford's relationship with Adolf Hitler. And the extraordinary thing is that this posh airhead, who you might think has nothing to offer at all, becomes part of Hitlerler's inner circle yeah
就像许多人一样，他被英国贵族阶层所吸引。从某种程度上说，他可能对尤妮蒂本人印象深刻。简单来说，希特勒在尤妮蒂身边时感到更快乐。所以，汤姆，这就是劳拉·汤普森在《六姐妹：米特福德姐妹的一生》中所讲述的内容。这才是故事真正的核心，不是吗？尤妮蒂·米特福德与阿道夫·希特勒的关系。最不可思议的是，这个你可能觉得一无是处的时髦“空心脑袋”，竟然成了希特勒核心圈子的一部分，没错。
so laura thompson's book is brilliant it's about all as the title implies it's about all the mitford sisters and she is much more generous to unity than david price jones is in his biography both of them are agreed that uh almost certainly there wasn't a sexual relationship between Hitler and therefore the entire premise of this episode has been destroyed. No, we'll come to the story that maybe Unity was carrying Hitler's love child later in the episode. But for now, let's act on the assumption that there's a platonic quality to Unity's relationship with Hitler. If that's the case, then what is going on? I think Laura Thompson absolutely fixes on it, which is that Hitler is charmed. So Laura Thompson talks about all the Mitford sisters having this yearning towards lightness,
所以劳拉·汤普森的书非常精彩，正如书名所暗示的那样，它讲述了所有米特福德姐妹的故事。她对尤妮蒂的态度比大卫·普莱斯·琼斯在他的传记中要宽容得多。他们两人都同意，呃，希特勒和尤妮蒂之间几乎肯定没有性关系，因此这一集的前提已经被推翻了。不，我们稍后会讲到关于尤妮蒂可能怀了希特勒私生子的传闻。但现在，让我们假设尤妮蒂与希特勒的关系是柏拉图式的。如果是这样，那到底发生了什么？我认为劳拉·汤普森完全抓住了重点，那就是希特勒被她迷住了。所以劳拉·汤普森谈到所有的米特福德姐妹都有一种对轻盈感的向往，
which I think is a kind of wonderful phrase. Even when you're going into the dark, they speak the language of the nursery. They talk to people with utmost confidence that everyone is going to be interested in what they have to say. And so that means that Unity perhaps is relaxed with Hitler in a way that very few people are, because most people are either terrified of him or desperate for something. But Unity has already got what she wants.
我觉得这是一个非常美妙的短语。即使在她们步入黑暗时，她们说的也是那种童言稚语。她们以极大的自信与人交谈，仿佛每个人都会对她们所说的话感兴趣。这意味着尤妮蒂在希特勒面前可能表现得非常放松，这是极少数人能做到的，因为大多数人要么对他感到恐惧，要么对他有所求。但尤妮蒂已经得到了她想要的。
She wants to hang out with him. And so now she can just kind of prattle away using all her kind of nursery language. Dear sweet Hitler. Is that what she calls him? The blissful Fuhrer. Yes. Oh, God.
她只想和他待在一起。所以现在她可以随心所欲地用那种童言稚语喋喋不休。亲爱的希特勒。她是这么叫他的吗？幸福的元首。是的。天哪。
Am I right in thinking, Tom? I read in your notes, she encourages Hitler to do impressions. She does. Yes. So she gets him to tell jokes and she gets him to do impressions, particularly of Mussolini, which apparently she finds so funny. So it's evident that Hitler is able to kind of relax with her and to be a tremendous laugh.
汤姆，我没理解错吧？我在你的笔记里读到，她鼓励希特勒模仿别人。是的，没错。所以她让他讲笑话，让他模仿别人，尤其是墨索里尼，她似乎觉得这非常有趣。很明显，希特勒在尤妮蒂面前能够放松下来，并且表现得非常爱笑。
All his impressions, all his gags flowing out in a way that normally, you know, doesn't associate with the dear, dear Fuhrer. So definitely unity amuses him. But I think there is also a sense he feels that she has been sent by fate because of the fact that her middle name is Valkyrie, because she was born in in swastika because her forebears are such significant figures in the history of anti-semitism he feels you know what are the odds that this girl would come from Britain with all these markers and he's quite superstitious you know he's the man of destiny I think that there's a slight element of that as well and so he he gives her considerable marks of favor so he gives her a gold swastika badge with his signature engraved on the back that are given to very, very few people.
他所有的模仿、所有的笑话都自然流露，这在通常情况下，你知道，人们不会把这些与那位亲爱的元首联系起来。所以尤妮蒂确实让他感到愉悦。但我认为还有一种感觉，他觉得她是命运派来的，因为她的中间名是“瓦尔基里”（Valkyrie），因为她出生在“万字旗”（Swastika）的日子，因为她的祖先在反犹太主义历史上是如此重要的人物。他觉得，你知道，这个女孩带着所有这些标志从英国来到这里，概率是多少呢？而且他非常迷信，你知道，他是天选之子，我觉得这其中也有轻微的因素。所以他给了她相当多的恩宠，比如他给了她一枚金质万字徽章，背面刻着他的签名，这种徽章只给极少数人。
He invites both Unity and Diana. So Unity introduces Diana to him. And you can imagine what a thrill that must have given the younger sister to introduce the glamorous elder sister to the Fuhrer. They get given splendid seats at the Olympic games. Hitler, rather naughtily, sits her next to Eva Braun, who is incredibly jealous and in fact stages a suicide attempt to try and get attention. And Hitler promptly does pay attention to Eva Braun. And so that again kind of alerts unity to the fact that melodrama and histrionics, this is how you keep hitler um interested i think unity is also playing a a kind of political role in a very gauche clumsy way because she is unbelievably indiscreet so anything she's told she will blab so hitler knows this so he can use her basically to communicate with upper class
他邀请了尤妮蒂和戴安娜。所以尤妮蒂把戴安娜介绍给了他。你可以想象，对于妹妹来说，把迷人的姐姐介绍给元首是多么令人兴奋。他们在奥运会上被安排了极好的座位。希特勒，相当淘气地，让她坐在爱娃·布劳恩旁边，爱娃非常嫉妒，甚至为了引起注意而上演了一场自杀未遂。希特勒立刻就去关注爱娃·布劳恩了。这再次提醒了尤妮蒂，情节剧和表演欲是让希特勒保持兴趣的方式。我认为尤妮蒂也以一种非常笨拙、粗鲁的方式扮演着某种政治角色，因为她极其不谨慎，所以无论被告知什么，她都会泄露出去。希特勒知道这一点，所以他基本上可以利用她与英国上流社会进行沟通。
circles in britain so there's an occasion where he he lets slip that he's crossed with Mussolini. Unity immediately reports that to all her contacts back in London. And before you know it, Foreign Office and Number 10 are buzzing with possibilities for peeling Hitler off Mussolini. And likewise, she's very indiscreet about what she's heard in London. So she tells Hitler that according to Randolph Churchill, London has no air def defenses. I mean, and this is verging on the treasonous. I don't think she thinks of it in those terms, but she is blabbing away. And I think what unity, what she is very patriotic. She's very, you know, she's very proud to be British, but she also loves Germany. She loves her darling Fuhrer.
圈子。所以有一次，他无意中透露了他对墨索里尼的不满。尤妮蒂立即向她在伦敦的所有联系人报告了这一点。没过多久，外交部和唐宁街10号就因为可能将希特勒从墨索里尼身边拉拢过来而议论纷纷。同样，她对在伦敦听到的消息也非常不谨慎。所以她告诉希特勒，据伦道夫·丘吉尔说，伦敦没有防空设施。我的意思是，这已经接近叛国了。我不认为她是以这种方式思考的，但她就是在那儿喋喋不休。我认为尤妮蒂，她非常爱国。她非常，你知道，她为自己是英国人感到自豪，但她也热爱德国。她热爱她亲爱的元首。
And I think she wants Britain and Germany to be in an alliance. And it may be that at the margins of her thoughts, she's thinking that she perhaps could play a role if perhaps the darling Fuhrer would marry her, you know, a kind of dynastic alliance. So as a school girl, she had told a friend of hers, her ambition when she grew up was to become the power behind a mighty throne. So perhaps there's an element of that i mean just to put that into context before the first world war the british elite had been very very pro-german people had loved traveling to german holiday when we did that podcast about holidays and people get those terrible spas all of that kind of thing people love german literature they love german philosophy you know intelligent thinking people and between the wars there are lots of people it's rather like
我认为她希望英国和德国结成联盟。也许在她的潜意识里，她认为如果亲爱的元首能娶她，她或许能发挥作用，你知道，这是一种王朝式的联姻。所以作为一个女学生，她曾告诉朋友，她长大后的抱负是成为强大王座背后的权力。所以也许有这方面的因素。我的意思是，为了说明背景，在第一次世界大战之前，英国精英阶层非常非常亲德。人们喜欢去德国度假，当我们做那期关于假期的播客时，人们会去那些糟糕的温泉疗养地，所有这些事情。人们热爱德国文学，热爱德国哲学，你知道，有思想的人。在两次世界大战之间，有很多人，这有点像
lord darlington and kazuya shiguro's novel the remains of the day people who think gosh the first of all was such a tragedy a friendship between britain and germany you know they're so like us they're so highbrow the germans tremendous culture all that sort of stuff so actually unity she's a very outlandish version of this yeah but there'd be lots of aristocrats back in britain and an intelligent well-educated people who would say yes britain and germany should be friends and actually should be the two great pillars of the world order and all this kind of stuff and the mitfords are all fascinated by germany with the exception of nancy who's a tremendous francophile and her fascination with power you know she goes to live in paris she has a famous romance
石黑一雄小说《长日留痕》中的达林顿勋爵，那些认为“天哪，第一次世界大战真是一场悲剧，英国和德国之间的友谊，你知道，他们和我们太像了，他们那么有教养，德国人有伟大的文化”等等的人。所以实际上，尤妮蒂是这种心态的一个非常古怪的版本。是的，但英国会有很多贵族和受过良好教育的聪明人会说，是的，英国和德国应该成为朋友，实际上应该成为世界秩序的两大支柱，诸如此类。米特福德一家都对德国着迷，除了南希，她是一个狂热的亲法派，她对权力的迷恋，你知道，她去巴黎生活，她有一段著名的恋情。
with a colonel in the the free french and she is making a statement there that she is not part of this obsession with germany that has shaded into overt sympathy with with fascism and nazism because diana is not the only member of her family who unity introduces to hitler so she gets her parents over lord reedsdale, aka Uncle Matthew, famous for thinking, you know, once a hun, always a hun. He's immediately charmed by Hitler. So also is Lady Reedsdale, who the first time she meets Hitler, despite not speaking German, she lectures him on the best way to make bread. Lord Reedsdale is completely won over by Hitler and he goes to the House of Lords and defends the Anschluss.
与一名自由法国军队的上校，她在那里表明她并不参与这种对德国的痴迷，这种痴迷已经演变成了对法西斯主义和纳粹主义的公开同情。因为戴安娜并不是尤妮蒂介绍给希特勒的唯一家庭成员，所以她把她的父母也带了过去。里兹代尔勋爵，又名马修叔叔，以认为“一日为匈奴人，终身为匈奴人”而闻名。他立刻被希特勒迷住了。里兹代尔夫人也是如此，她第一次见到希特勒时，尽管不会说德语，却向他传授了制作面包的最佳方法。里兹代尔勋爵完全被希特勒征服了，他去了上议院并为德奥合并辩护。
Lady Reesdale goes even further, goes back, starts writing articles overtly in favor of Hitler, becomes very hostile to Churchill, calls him that wicked man, becomes devoted to the protocols of the elders of Zion. That very sinister text, you know, all the darkest anti-Semitic tropes and kind of writes too true and i always said so in the margin oh so lady reestel is going full in meanwhile of course there's diana uh hitler is very taken with diana as well very handsome and describes diana in unity as perfect examples of aryan womanhood and diana in turn is able to smooth the way for mosley so they go over to germany and they actually get married in goebbels drawing room even though goebbels doesn't like them hitler insists on it and hitler is at the wedding unity interestingly isn't because it's still the wedding has to be kept secret at this point and they know that if unity's there she'll blab she'll tell
里兹代尔夫人走得更远，回去后开始公开撰写支持希特勒的文章，对丘吉尔变得非常敌视，称他为“那个邪恶的人”，并开始致力于《锡安长老会纪要》。那份非常阴险的文本，你知道，所有最黑暗的反犹太主义比喻，她在页边空白处写道“太真实了，我早就说过”。哦，所以里兹代尔夫人是彻底陷进去了。与此同时，当然还有戴安娜，希特勒也非常看重戴安娜，非常英俊，并将戴安娜和尤妮蒂描述为雅利安女性的完美典范。戴安娜反过来能够为莫斯利铺平道路。所以他们去了德国，甚至在戈培尔的客厅里结婚，尽管戈培尔不喜欢他们，但希特勒坚持要这样做，而且希特勒参加了婚礼。有趣的是，尤妮蒂没有参加，因为婚礼在当时必须保密，他们知道如果尤妮蒂在场，她会泄露出去，她会告诉
everybody but of course hitler and mosley didn't think much of each other did they because we were talking a previous episode about whether mosley would have been the british fuhrer i don't know if the nazis invaded britain or something and actually hitler and mosley held each other in quite low regard but i think there's a sense of you know alpha males kind of squaring up right and so the uh again this is part of the the social dynamic of what's going on i mean it's like a kind of very dark social comedy so pamela the second mitford sister she meets hitler describes him as being like an old farmer in a brown suit and she goes on to marry a fascist sympathizer who nevertheless serves very bravely in the war tom the uh the the only son he he meets hitler and
所有人。但当然，希特勒和莫斯利并不怎么看得起对方，不是吗？因为我们在上一集讨论过莫斯利是否会成为英国的元首，如果纳粹入侵英国什么的。实际上，希特勒和莫斯利对彼此的评价都很低。但我认为有一种感觉，你知道，阿尔法雄性在对峙。所以，这又是正在发生的事情的社会动态的一部分。我的意思是，这就像一种非常黑暗的社会喜剧。帕梅拉，第二个米特福德姐妹，她见到希特勒时形容他就像一个穿着棕色西装的老农夫，她后来嫁给了一个法西斯同情者，尽管如此，他在战争中服役非常勇敢。汤姆，呃，唯一的儿子，他见到了希特勒，
his sympathies with Germany and by extension, Nazism are such that he insists on serving against the Japanese where he dies in the war in Burma. Deborah, who is very, very apolitical, but she goes and meets him. In fact, the only members of the family who don't meet Hitler are Nancy and Jessica, the communist. And Violet Hammersley, who was a family friend of the she wrote to Nancy and said you Mitfords you do like dictators which is obviously very true but obviously for aristocratic people like the Mitfords to go back to your thing about class as well Tom they would regard democracy and sort of non-violence and stuff they'd regard them as awful vulgar suburban middle-class values wouldn't? No, I don't think so.
他对德国的同情，进而对纳粹主义的同情，使他坚持要求在对日作战中服役，最终他在缅甸的战争中牺牲了。黛博拉，她非常非常不关心政治，但她也去见了他。事实上，家里唯一没见过希特勒的是南希和共产主义者杰西卡。维奥莱特·哈默斯利，她是家庭朋友，她写信给南希说：“你们米特福德家的人确实喜欢独裁者”，这显然是非常真实的。但显然，对于像米特福德家这样的贵族来说，回到你关于阶级的问题，汤姆，他们会认为民主、非暴力之类的东西是可怕、庸俗、郊区中产阶级的价值观，不是吗？不，我不这么认为。
Not necessarily. I mean, Deborah Debo, who goes on to marry the man who in due course becomes the Duke of Devonshire. I mean, she's a kind of classic conservative. Yeah, but the others, but Diana, Unity, they would think of them as middle-class and bourgeois and boring. And they would think of dictators as fun, wouldn't they? They love dressing up. Isn't that wonderful?
不一定。我的意思是，黛博拉·德博，后来嫁给了最终成为德文郡公爵的人。我的意思是，她是一个典型的保守派。是的，但其他人，戴安娜、尤妮蒂，她们会认为那些是中产阶级、资产阶级和无聊的。她们会认为独裁者很有趣，不是吗？她们喜欢打扮。那不是很棒吗？
Yes, I think that's true. And I think that that hence the phrase frivolity of evil. But I think if you are tempted by that to think there isn't really any harm being done, there are dimensions to unity's behavior that I think are completely shocking. So this terrible story is told that she comes back from Germany and she tells her siblings how in Germany she'd met an old woman who was very obviously Jewish, loaded down with lots of bags. And the woman asks Unity the way to the railway station. And Unity, I told her the wrong way because I saw how heavy the bundle was. Wasn't that wonderful of me?
是的，我认为这是真的。我认为这就是“邪恶的轻浮”这个短语的由来。但我认为，如果你因此认为这并没有造成真正的伤害，那么尤妮蒂的行为中有些层面我认为是完全令人震惊的。有一个可怕的故事，说她从德国回来后，告诉她的兄弟姐妹她在德国遇到了一位显然是犹太人的老妇人，身上背着很多包。那个女人问尤妮蒂去火车站的路。尤妮蒂说：“我给她指了错误的方向，因为我看到那个包裹有多重。我这样做不是很棒吗？”
Oh, what a monster. What a monster. And here is a former friend of Unity's who'd been at art college with her. Once she boasted that it was such fun to have supper with Stryker as you'd have the Jews in after the meal they'd be brought up from the cellar and be made to eat grass that entertained the guests oh Tom this is very bad form I mean this is there's there's no um no there's nothing funny about that at all and so she becomes increasingly notorious in England so there's um a famous ditty is published in one of the papers about her you can't criticize Unity with impunity if If you try to belittle her, you have to answer to Hitler. She gets caught up in a riot in Hyde Park,. And she stays committed to Hitler,
哦，真是个怪物。真是个怪物。这是一位尤妮蒂以前的朋友，曾和她一起在艺术学院学习。她曾吹嘘说，和斯特莱克一起吃晚饭真有趣，因为饭后犹太人会被从地窖里带上来，被迫吃草，这让客人们感到娱乐。哦，汤姆，这太没教养了，我的意思是，这根本没有任何有趣的地方。所以她在英国变得越来越臭名昭著。有一首关于她的著名打油诗发表在报纸上：“你不能不受惩罚地批评尤妮蒂，如果你试图贬低她，你就得回答希特勒的问题。”她卷入了海德公园的一场骚乱，但她仍然忠于希特勒，
even as it becomes increasingly evident that Britain is going to be going to war with Germany. So 1939, she goes to Bayreuth, the festival there with Diana. And Hitler basically says to them, look, you should get out of Germany because we are going to be going to war. And Diana duly goes back home,
即使英国即将与德国开战变得越来越明显。所以1939年，她和戴安娜一起去了拜罗伊特参加那里的音乐节。希特勒基本上对她们说，看，你们应该离开德国，因为我们要开战了。戴安娜按时回到了家，
but unity stays there. And maybely goes back home but unity stays there and maybe one of the reasons why unity stays there and a very physical evidence both of Hitler's favor and of her desire to become German is that Hitler has given her a flat so he had given her a choice of four flats in Munich she'd gone around she'd chosen the one that she wanted went around the house saying oh these curtains won't do at all. We must get rid of this awful sofa. Meanwhile, the two people who are being dispossessed, both of whom are Jewish, are sitting in the hallway sobbing. She pays them no attention at all. So this is the background to the most famous incident in her life, which is when war is declared.
但尤妮蒂留在了那里。也许尤妮蒂留在那里的原因之一，也是希特勒的恩宠和她渴望成为德国人的一个非常具体的证据，是希特勒给了她一套公寓。他给了她慕尼黑四套公寓的选择，她四处看了看，选了她想要的那一套，然后在房子里走来走去说：“哦，这些窗帘根本不行。我们必须扔掉这张糟糕的沙发。”与此同时，那两个被驱逐的人，都是犹太人，正坐在走廊里啜泣。她根本没理会他们。这就是她一生中最著名事件的背景，也就是战争爆发的时候。
Britain declares war on germany she goes she's in munich she's in her flat that where she's living that's been taken from the jewish couple she goes to the english garden in munich uh she has a very small caliber kind of pearl handle pistol she shoots herself through the head cracking but the bullet is isn't sufficiently you know it's a small caliber bullet so it doesn doesn't kill her. She's found, she's bundled into an ambulance, taken to the hospital. She's recognized. Hitler sends her flowers, Goebbels, Ribbentrop, they all send her flowers. And on the 10th of September, you know, even as the war with Britain is in its opening weeks, Hitler finds time to come and visit her. And she doesn't recognize him because she's mentally shot. And as she comes to, she tries to commit suicide a second time by swallowing
英国对德国宣战，她当时在慕尼黑，在她那套从犹太夫妇手中夺来的公寓里。她去了慕尼黑的英国花园，她有一把非常小口径的珍珠柄手枪，她朝自己的头部开了一枪，但子弹不够，你知道，那是一颗小口径子弹，所以没能杀死她。她被发现，被塞进救护车，送往医院。她被认出来了。希特勒给她送了花，戈培尔、里宾特洛甫，他们都给她送了花。9月10日，你知道，即使与英国的战争正处于初期阶段，希特勒还是抽出时间去看望她。她认不出他，因为她精神上已经崩溃了。当她清醒过来时，她试图通过吞下
her swastika badge, but that doesn't work. And it's only after six weeks that she recaptures her ability to speak. And on the 8th of November, Hitler comes again. It's the last time they meet. And Hitler says, you know, what do you want? Do you want to stay here? Or do you want to be sent back to England? And she says, I would like to go back to England and so he arranges for her to be taken to Bern in neutral Switzerland and the phony war is still on so it's perfectly possible for her to be taken by rail from Switzerland all the way back to England so her mother and Debo her younger sister go and get her I, it must have been hideous for her that, you know, being jolted along the bullet in her head. When she arrives in Folkestone,
她的万字徽章来第二次自杀，但没有成功。六周后，她才恢复了说话的能力。11月8日，希特勒又来了。这是他们最后一次见面。希特勒说，你知道，你想要什么？你想留在这里吗？还是想被送回英国？她说，我想回英国。于是他安排她被送往中立的瑞士伯尔尼。当时“假战”还在继续，所以她完全可以通过铁路从瑞士一路回到英国。她的母亲和妹妹德博去接她。我，那对她来说一定很可怕，你知道，带着头里的子弹被颠簸着。当她到达福克斯通时，
there's a kind of tremendous scandal because there seem to be armed guards everywhere. And this will become the subject of much public criticism. And it's uncertain whether the armed guards are there to stop people from looking at her or whether they're just coincidental. But there is this feeling that she is getting special treatment that would not be afforded to other people. To protect her from the crowds and the press, presumably. Yes. And so in the comments, Herbert Morrison, who will of course go on to become Home Secretary in the coalition government, he describes her as a British subject who had been openly assisting the cause of an enemy government and asks, would a working class person receive similar treatment? Well, he's right. Yeah, he is absolutely right.
发生了一场巨大的丑闻，因为到处似乎都有武装警卫。这将成为公众批评的主题。目前还不确定武装警卫是在那里阻止人们看她，还是仅仅是巧合。但人们确实感觉到她受到了其他普通人无法享受的特殊待遇。大概是为了保护她免受人群和媒体的骚扰。是的。所以在评论中，赫伯特·莫里森，他当然会成为联合政府的内政大臣，他形容她是一个公开协助敌国事业的英国臣民，并问道：“一个工人阶级的人会受到同样的待遇吗？”嗯，他是对的。是的，他完全正确。
Think about the cases of British citizens, British subjects. Yeah, Shamima Begum. Who have been, you know, working with the Islamic State or whatever. I think Unity Mitford should have been dropped into the channel from a great height, personally. Well, so lots of people do, but she isn't. She goes to the Radcliffe in Oxford. There, they say there's no chance of extracting the bullet from her brain.
想想那些英国公民、英国臣民的案例。是的，沙米玛·贝古姆。那些一直与伊斯兰国或其他组织合作的人。我个人认为尤妮蒂·米特福德应该被从高空扔进海峡。嗯，很多人都这么想，但她没有。她去了牛津的拉德克利夫医院。在那里，他们说从她大脑中取出子弹是不可能的。
And so she is left, essentially, it's said, the mental age of a 10-year-old, a bright 10-year-old. She's left permanently incontinent. She's kind of described by people as a kind of large dog. She's shambolic. She's kind of her limbs going everywhere. She's like a kind of, you know as a kind of large dog. She's shambolic. She's kind of her limbs going everywhere. She's like a kind of, you know, a big, an enormous puppy. Tom, just on the suicide attempt.
所以她基本上被留在了那里，据说智力水平相当于一个10岁的孩子，一个聪明的10岁孩子。她终身失禁。人们形容她就像一只大狗。她行动迟缓，她的四肢到处乱晃。她就像一种，你知道，一只巨大的小狗。汤姆，关于自杀未遂。
The suicide attempt is the day that Britain declares war on Germany. Is that right? The 3rd of September. And this is because it's not just that her two beloved countries are going to war with each other. But is it also that she has been proved so comprehensively wrong that all her silly who knows daydreams and fantasies uh oh we just don't know we just haven't is there any sense of guilt before she does it i mean she never says she never really talks about it does she remember it nobody knows and i i i don't know i'm guessing it's the tension you know all her dreams were vested in this dream of this alliance between Britain and Germany.
自杀未遂是在英国对德国宣战的那一天吗？是这样吗？9月3日。这是因为不仅她深爱的两个国家要开战了，而且是否也因为她被证明是如此彻底地错了，她所有那些愚蠢的白日梦和幻想……哦，我们只是不知道，我们只是没有……她在做这件事之前有任何负罪感吗？我的意思是，她从来没有说过，她从来没有真正谈论过它，不是吗？没人知道，我不知道，我猜是压力，你知道，她所有的梦想都寄托在这个英国和德国结盟的梦想上。
But anyway, basically, to cut a long story short, she never really recovers. And in due course, she gets meningitis and dies at the age of 33. So I think in 1948. So yes, after the war, she's never in prison. So unlike her sister, Diana, who gets locked up in Holloway, she's never imprisoned. On her parents, her parents, they split up in the war, didn't they? They do, because the moment that Britain declares war on Germany, Lord Reesdale, who is an absolute patriot, swings behind the British war effort, goes back to thinking that the Huns are beastly. Lady Reesdale doesn't. Lady Reesdale remains an enthusiast for Hitler. Yeah. And, you know, succession of tragedies over one. So they split up. Jessica, the communist
但总之，长话短说，她从未真正康复。后来，她患上了脑膜炎，在33岁时去世了。所以我想是在1948年。所以是的，战后她从未入狱。所以不像她的姐姐戴安娜，被关在霍洛威监狱，她从未被监禁。关于她的父母，她的父母在战争中分开了，不是吗？是的，因为英国对德国宣战的那一刻，里兹代尔勋爵，一个绝对的爱国者，转而支持英国的战争努力，重新开始认为匈奴人是野兽。里兹代尔夫人没有。里兹代尔夫人仍然是希特勒的狂热支持者。是的。而且，你知道，一系列的悲剧接踵而至。所以他们分开了。杰西卡，那个共产主义者
sister, has gone to America. She doesn't come back. She, you know, kind of absolute sense of rupture between her and her parents. Tom dies in Burma. And then you have the death of Unity in 1948 of meningitis. And the question, Tom, which Theo, our producer, desperately wants you to answer, is whether she was carrying Hitler's child when she returned to Britain. Right. So this was a theory that was prompted by the release of declassified documents in 2002, which quoted an MI5 officer called Guy Liddell, who said, we had no evidence to support the press allegations that she was in a serious state of health, and it might well be that
姐妹，去了美国。她没有回来。她，你知道，她和父母之间有一种绝对的决裂感。汤姆在缅甸去世了。然后是1948年尤妮蒂因脑膜炎去世。汤姆，我们的制片人西奥非常想让你回答的问题是，她回到英国时是否怀着希特勒的孩子。好的。所以这个理论是由2002年解密文件的发布引发的，文件中引用了一位名叫盖伊·利德尔的军情五处官员的话，他说：“我们没有证据支持媒体关于她处于严重健康状态的指控，很有可能她被用担架抬进来是为了避免公众关注和给家人带来不快。”所以这导致了她从未真正开枪自杀的理论。如果她从未开枪自杀，为什么希特勒让她离开？于是随之而来的理论是，实际上她怀着他的孩子。这就是她回来的方式。当时《新政治家》的政治编辑马丁·布莱特接到了一位女性的电话，她声称尤妮蒂·米特福德去过牛津的一家私人妇产医院。所以把二加二加起来等于八。这个理论是尤妮蒂·米特福德怀了希特勒的私生子，这个孩子随后被带走，送去寄养。因此，多米尼克，希特勒王朝可能正游荡在科茨沃尔德，即使在你现在坐着的时候。我的意思是，坦率地说，如果你遇到一些科茨沃尔德的人，你也不会完全感到惊讶。
she was brought in on a stretcher in order to avoid publicity and unpleasantness to her family. So that led to the theory that she'd never actually shot herself. And if she'd never shot herself, why did Hitler let her go away? And so the theory that then came that actually she was burying his child. This is how she came back. And Martin Bright, who was the political editor of the New Statesman at the time, he received a phone call from a woman who claimed that Unity Mitford had gone to a private maternity hospital in Oxford. And so putting two and two together and coming up with eight. The theory was that Unity Mitford had Hitler's love child, that this child was then taken away, brought for fostering. And therefore, Dominic, the Hitler dynasty may be roaming the Cotswolds, even as you sit there now. I mean, frankly, if you met some people from the Cotswolds, you wouldn't be entirely surprised.
好吧，就是这样。所以我认为这不太可能。我们就这么说吧。这对我来说似乎非常不可能。嗯，我不认为任何希特勒传记作者会给这个理论哪怕一点点空间，对吧？或者实际上，我认为许多米特福德学者也不会。事实上，有米特福德学者，事实上他们是如此持久迷恋的对象，我认为这很有趣，因为我认为有一种感觉，尤妮蒂和戴安娜所做的一切，正如我所说，已经成为遗产产业的一部分。我认为原因基本上是南希·米特福德在写《追求爱》和《冷气候中的爱》时，这些是非常精彩的小说，对她的成长经历进行了如此深情的渲染。而且
Well, there you go. So I think it's unlikely. Let's put it like that. It seems very unlikely to me. Well, I don't think any Hitler biographer would give this theory the slightest house room, would they? Or indeed, I think many Mitford scholars either. And the fact that there are Mitford scholars, the fact that they are the subject of such enduring fascination, I think is interesting because I think there is a sense that what both Unity and Diana did, as I said, it's become part of the heritage industry. And I think the reason for that is basically that Nancy Mitford, when she wrote The Pursuit of Love and Love in a Cold Climate, these are such brilliant novels, such an affectionate rendering of her upbringing. And
她从她的各个姐妹身上提取元素，并将她们融入叙事中的角色，这使得戴安娜和尤妮蒂的法西斯倾向看起来有些古怪，有些迷人。我认为迷人，有邪恶的魅力，我想这听起来很可怕，尤其是当你听到尤妮蒂行为的故事时。是的，所以对于尤妮蒂，你有她早逝的事实，而对于莫斯利夫人，你有她直到最后都保持着惊人的美丽的事实。所以劳拉·汤普森在她精彩的书里描述了她晚年的样子，一个高大的幽灵，
she takes elements of her various sisters and folds them into characters within the narrative that it's made the fascist affiliations of both diana and unity seem something eccentric something glamorous i think glamorous there's the glamour of evil i think that's as horrible as that sounds especially when you hear the stories of unit's behavior yeah so with unity you have the you know that her early death and with lady mostly have the fact that she remained stunningly beautiful right the way up to the end. So Laura Thompson in her wonderful book describes her in her final years, a tall wraith
像一缕精致的灰白色长烟，90岁时依然美丽。嗯，她会出现在那些脱口秀节目上，汤姆，不是吗？在20世纪70年代、80年代？嗯，多米尼克，我会读给你听她在《荒岛唱片》上说的话，当主持人苏·劳利问她关于大屠杀以及她是否相信六百万这个数字时，她的回答是：“我恐怕不太相信六百万人
like a long exquisite wisp of grey white smoke, entirely beautiful at the age of 90. Well she would be appearing on these chat shows Tom wouldn't she in the 1970s, 1980s? Well Dominic I'll read you what she said on Desert Island Discs when Sue Lawley the presenter asked her about the holocaust and whether she believed in the six million figure and her reply i don't really i'm afraid believe that six million people
被杀害了，我认为这根本不可想象。太多了，但无论是六百万还是一个，在道德上都没有区别，这完全是错误的，我认为这是一件非常邪恶的事情。”这真是令人震惊。我的意思是，当然，她承认希特勒做了邪恶的事情，但她在BBC首屈一指的广播采访节目中参与了大屠杀否认。是的。在1989年。这太不可思议了。实际上，我的意思是，莫斯利夫人和奥斯瓦尔德爵士似乎都没有被负罪感所折磨，也没有任何负罪感或遗憾，或者任何这些东西。我认为对于戴安娜来说，正是因为
were killed i think this is just not conceivable it's too many but whether it's six or whether it's one makes no difference morally it's completely wrong i think it was a dreadfully wicked thing so that's pretty mind-blowing i mean, sure, she's acknowledging that Hitler did wicked things, but she is engaging in Holocaust denial on the BBC's premiere radio interview show. Yeah. In 1989. It's extraordinary. And actually, I mean, neither Lady Mosley nor Sir Oswald ever really seemed to have been crippled by guilt or had any sense of guilt or regret or any of these things. And I think with Diana, it's precisely because
她绝对坚持对奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利的忠诚。而且因为他们都有那种贵族式的、傲慢的自信，不是吗？他们从来不会认为，你知道，再次强调，说“哦，我很抱歉我犯了错误”之类的会显得很庸俗和郊区化。他们有这种不可战胜的自信。我的意思是，我们离开莫斯利，只是为了总结他的故事，我们在第二次世界大战中把他留在监狱里了，不是吗？他在1943年11月因健康原因获释，实际上他余生的故事基本上无关紧要。他获释了，他是一个有毒的人物。他建立了一个叫“联盟运动”的组织，奇怪的是，他主张欧洲
she absolutely holds to her devotion to Oswald Moseley. And also because they both have this sort of aristocratic, this bumptious self-confidence, don't they? They don't ever think, you know, again, it would be bourgeois and suburban to say, oh, I feel sorry I've made mistakes and all these kinds of things. They have this kind of invincible assurance self-assurance i mean we left mosley just to wrap up his story we left mosley in prison didn't we in um in the second world war he was released on medical grounds in november 1943 and actually the rest of his story his life is kind of an irrelevance really he's released's released, he's kind of a toxic figure. He sets up something called the Union Movement, arguing, bizarrely as it may sound, for European
统一。但这是一种，你知道，反对布尔什维主义的基督教统一等等。这有点像作为一种伪装的法西斯堡垒来对抗共产主义的欧盟。然后他转向反移民，所以它不再那么反犹太，而是对从南亚和加勒比地区移居英国的人更加种族主义。所以那是在20世纪50年代末，他实际上在1959年再次在北肯辛顿参加选举，并获得了8%的选票。所以这是在一个发生过种族主义骚乱的地区，他仍然表现得很差。是的，诺丁山。所以他仍然表现得很差，这标志着他的名声有多么糟糕。
unity. But it's a sort of, you know, Christian unity against Bolshevism and all this kind of thing. It's kind of the European Union as a kind of disguised fascist bulwark against communism. He then moves into anti-immigration so that it's not so anti-semitic but it's more racist against people who've moved to britain from south asia and the caribbean so that's in the late 1950s he actually stands for election again in north kensington in 1959 and receives eight percent of the vote so this is in an area where there have been racist riots and he still does very badly yeah notting hill so he still does very badly which is a sign of how toxic his reputation
英国法西斯联盟显然已经解散了，它最终进入了其他极右翼运动，你知道，20世纪70年代、80年代的英国国民党、国民阵线。但我的意思是，最终这些都是相当小的组织，根本不可能赢得一个议会席位。与此同时，他去了巴黎。是的，完全正确，你知道，有点像温莎公爵夫妇。是的，实际上他亲密的邻居，我们忘记的事情，因为在20世纪，我记得成长过程中，你知道，奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利是那种名字，他是极右翼种族主义的象征，但他也是一个荒谬的人物，因为他是一个彻底的失败者。
has been the british union of fascists obviously has broken up it goes into eventually into other far-right movements you know the british national party the national front in the 1970s 1980s but i mean ultimately these are quite small organizations that are never remotely likely to win a single parliamentary seat and meanwhile he's gone to paris yes exactly you know a bit like the duke and duchess of windsor yeah and actually his close neighbors the thing that we forget because in the certainly i remember growing up you know oswald mosley was this sort of name he was the symbol of of far- racism, but also he was a ludicrous figure because he was such a failure.
但实际上，忘记这一点吧，在20世纪20年代和30年代，有很多人认为他有一天可能会成为首相，他是一个严肃而富有想象力的政治思想家。然后他进行了一系列愚蠢的赌博，离开工党，建立新党，然后是英国法西斯联盟，这实际上导致了死胡同，因为我认为法西斯主义在英国没有空间，你知道，它没有足够的空间来扩张，因为议会制度太有韧性了。关键是英国赢得了第一次世界大战，所以实际上它最终与像米特福德一家这样的古怪人物联系在一起，并且我认为它从未真正赢得英国中产阶级的心。你觉得呢，汤姆？嗯，在做了四集关于它的节目后，
But actually, forget that in the 1920s and 1930s, there were a lot of people who thought he might one day be prime minister, that he was a serious and imaginative political thinker. And then he made those series of stupid gambles, leaving Labour Party the new setting up the new party then the BUF that actually led nowhere because fascism I think in Britain had nowhere to you know it didn't have enough space to expand into because the parliamentary system was too resilient crucially Britain won the first world war so actually it ends up being associated with the eccentric people like the Mitfords and never really wins over middle England I would say what do you think Tom well having done four episodes on it,
说它从根本上并不重要，也许不是结束的方式。我认为，重要和有趣之间是有区别的。绝对是。嗯，所以，所以尤妮蒂。
saying that fundamentally it wasn't very important is perhaps not the nature of which to end. I think there's a, I think there's a difference between being important and being interesting. Absolutely. Well, so hence, hence unity.
是的。我的意思是，她给我的印象是，你那么热衷于做这件事，我以为你要提出一种对米特福德一家的修正主义观点，但实际上在做这个之前，我就对她们评价非常非常低。
Yeah. I mean, she strikes me, you were so keen to do, I thought you were going to present a kind of revisionist account of the Mitfords, but actually I held them in very, very low regard before we did this.
汤姆，我现在对她们的评价比一小时前还要低。所以，嗯，那些经营米特福德遗产产业的人，他们不应该打电话来感谢你，尽管她们故事的性质很可能是，可能会有人听了这些，然后想“我要去斯温布鲁克的那个墓地看看她们的坟墓”。嗯，正如我所说，我认为这完全归功于南希，我认为她是一位非常伟大的小说家、作家，我认为她的虚构作品的力量证明了，她为所有其他更可怕的姐妹披上了一层金色的光泽。她也是一个极其势利的人，所以在我看来，她不是“历史的其余部分”的朋友。好的，汤姆，非常感谢你。
And I actually held them in lower regard now than i did an hour ago tom so um the people who run the mitford heritage industry you know they should not be ringing to thank you although probably the nature of their story is such that probably there'll be people who listen to this and think i'll go over to that graveyard and swinbrook and check out their graves and well i as i say i think it's all down to nancy who i think was a great great novelist writer and i think that it's testimony to the power of her fiction that um she has cast such a kind of golden luster over the all the other more monstrous sisters she was also an absolutely towering snob so not a friend of the rest is history in my mind mind at least. Okay, Tom, thank you very much.
那真是太迷人了。感谢大家的收听。我们下周一会回来，带来一些绝对非法西斯主题的内容。所以我们到时候见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
That was absolutely fascinating. Thank you to everybody for listening. And we will be returning next week on Monday with some absolutely non-fascist themed material. So we will see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们共同主持《其余的都是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的来源，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。